dernier jour du procès en appel de jean
pierre murat accusé du meurtre de
christelle mairi il ya 30 ans l'homme
avait été condamné à 20 ans de prison en
première instance
pauline ringenbach vous êtes sur place
les jurés se sont retirés il ya plus de
quatre heures pauline wii est le verdict
devrait être rendu d'un instant à
l'autre visiblement la cour et les jurés
ont du mal à se mettre d'accord sur le
sort de jean pierre murat est il
coupable de ce meurtre commis le 18
décembre 1986 ce jour-là christelle
mairi a donc été tués de 31 coups de
couteau dans une cave du quartier de la
charmille au creusot la famille de
christelle attend donc la vérité
maintenant depuis trente ans en première
instance comme vous l'avez dit jean
pierre murat a donc été condamné à 20
ans de réclusion criminelle
alors est ce que cette peine va être
confirmé comme la dombes il a demandé
l'avocat général lors de ses
réquisitions c'est toute la question et
cette attente très longue et qui est
rarement aussi longue et donc forcément
pénible à vivre pour les parties civiles
je vous propose d'écouter leurs
impressions stressé donc qu'est-ce que
c'est le dé la délibération est très
longue depuis 13h30 quoi on attend donc
on a hâte parce que ben ouais ça fait
peur quoique nous la peur on a peur mais
la peur mais en même temps on est très
confiant parce que on a
un avocat nous avocats l'avocat général
ils ont été très bons ça fait donc plus
de cinq heures que l'ambiance l'audience
est suspendue
je vous propose d'écouter maintenant la
réaction de maître ce banc pour la
famille ça a été plutôt la souffrance de
la douleur de revivre la mort de
christelle et de voir l'attitude de
l'accusé qui n'a rien lâché
c'est même beaucoup plus tu clan
première instance
donc voilà le droit nous imposer ce
procès en appel c'est une garantie
légitime mais ça a été je pense un
nouvel nouveau moment de douleur forte
pour la famille
l'avocate l'avocate de la défense qui a
plaidé pendant plus d'une heure et demie
l'acquittement de son client a donc
peut-être instiller le doute dans
l'esprit des jurés sur le conseil
régional à présent en direct avec eric
sékou pour faire le point sur cette
journée cruciale à dijon attention